ich freue mich drauf klar ich komme es
doch klar dass herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video ich darf heute daran
dachten okay was gibt heute auf dem man
da kam mir der gedanke hat für uns heute
mal die ersten videos von youtube am
rhein ziehen könnten ich dachte es ist
ziemlich wirklich viele youtube das
schon lange machen sich mega kraft
verändern im laufe ihrer karriere und am
ende nicht für die gleich belohnt
eigentlich ich hoffe dass du dieses
video main kanal nicht gelöscht wird
wir haben familie zu versorgen wird er
hat erbarmen acht kinder wollen neue
edith haben jeden monat also weiter habe
ich doch mal an minuten dessen erstes
video was mit den plan heißt let verlieh
vertrieb most wanted parteien need for
speed most wanted alter wie gaildorf war
natürlich das ist ein spiel der
fachkraft das doch mit trailer oder wie
ich liebe dieses spiel werde die
bespielung gpa talent wert sind mein
leben es nicht übertrieben ich liebe
dieses spiel wirklich einfach nur ja ja
genau diese straßen genau diese staaten
jeder der das spiel gespielt hat weiß
wovon ich rede
leider ist okay dass man vermuten
trainer spielen lassen aber das video
ist halt auch einfach schon es ist über
vier jahre alte sven thiele und einem
monat kraft sehr viel jammern oder
herzlich willkommen zu meinem letzten
need for speed most wanted minuten bei
name ist vermuten schön dass hier
irgendwie den weg für dieses video
gefunden habe ja dann würde ich einfach
mal sagen versuchen wir einer der most
wanted von verhelfen werden aber ich
muss sagen vermuten macht echt guten
eindruck versucht macht wirklich guten
eindruck in seinem ersten video dafür
dass es wieder vier jahre alte hut ab
dafür kommentierte recht ordentlich und
das
aber ganz so schnell aber irgendwie das
spiel anders aus das sieht nicht nach
dem most wanted auf dass ich so kenne
mich in der konsolenversion aus wanted
war auch dieses klassischen spiel mit
dem m3 oder ich hab noch gar nicht zu
sprechen von sagen aber ins spiel die
bürgersteige schnell unfassbar
dann schauen wir doch mal ab dem
nächsten youtuber das ist krieg das
erkennt man halt wirklich nicht immer
nur die vermehrte sieht sein erstes
video was man hier einsehen kann ist
black ops 2
wie kommt mein lieblingsgegner 110
keine ahnung was sein wird jo alter
sogar noch richtig richtig uraltes in
vorarlberg hinterher über die ganzen
sachen jetzt natürlich von der heutigen
perspektive nähert ist klar dass sohn
intro heute vielleicht eher nicht mehr
so aktuell ist aber wahrscheinlich macht
als pure das video by email vom 30 12
2012 kehrt damen und herren und call of
duty spieler erstmal kate system starten
so ne ich präsentiert heute ein echt
geiles game play okay der ärzte hat
genau so angefangen wie ich darf mir
auch damals egal was für leute möchte
ich cool finden und was später einmal
übertreibt einfach so man hat mich mega
übertriebene aussprache und redet halt
nicht so natürlich wie bluttest gemacht
hat sich klocke mit der mz wir gerade
sehen könnt ihr gleich doppelt in die er
mit kämpfe mich die am besten an die am
meisten spielen dmp in black ops wird
durch natürlich die npd 57 noch ein
bisschen besser gemacht war bin laden
aber man hat viel mehr
in einem magazin aber sie schlecht also
ich glaub auch das ding ist er bei
dieser ganzen community
red scorpion wird tabarka kehrt
wahrscheinlich auch die alle bekannt
wurden bei dem anfang halt ganz gut
gespielt haben und dann nicht angefangen
haben es mit 1000 karten zu
durchschneiden dass du dich ist dass
leute hier jung zu bestreiten weil noch
plus brief a rock and roll übertreiben
über war zuvor österreich gesprächen
aber dem titel selbst gleich schneiden
wenn ich nur österreichische würde
besser keinen punkt world einzustehen
hoch beutels freuen
was hatte gegen hochdeutsch sprechende
kleinem anteil wirkt ein bisschen
gekünstelt aber auch der macht echten
guten job in dem ersten video für online
hat alles klar machen wir weiter mit wie
man mit um gespielt dessen ältestes
video was man jetzt noch gehen kann ist
auch jahre altes aller ältestes
letztlich länder aber damit kann ich
nicht viel anfangen deswegen schauen wir
zwar fange games4mac reihen games an und
wer von euch schon bald arbeitsplätze
prime games programmgebiet danach pixeln
auf und hat heute einfach hin und mach'
mein kopf mehr sondern fashion.de
wirklich wahrscheinlich hatten dafür
aber da bekomme ich meinen blick nicht
mehr in den alten rom sollen auch in den
alten job der nova und je
auf jeden fall dass das blatt gesagt
komm lass in hunger games gehen wo wir
sind und ich kenne schon lange ganz
einfach gar nicht aus neue gefahr dass
mögliche class damals war einfach
qualität wirklich vollkommen egal also
an meinen ersten videos war dass auch
dort hatte ich auch hier oben so
schwarze balken und hatte so ein richtig
richtig schlechtes an qualität und
dadurch nur sagen sekunden mit er weiß
auch um gespielt
er war aus seinem plan ab ach du scheiße
koers graz graz graz graz das video von
700 auf 2012 aber diesmal auf den
oktober 2012 und ja das hört sich schon
das andere muss man sagen ist aber auch
ganz mal vor dem stimmbruch das klingt
natürlich wieder anderer menschen nach
hause rausspringen ich bin sehr gut und
die leitern hoch wirklich wichtig ist
ich habe nicht ich hab nicht ich okay
ich kenne aber hier ein tor machen ich
freue mich drauf klar ich komme ich
nicht auch klar und einfach schon drei
minuten und haben keine waffen auch
richtig klasse von dem boden und war
wichtig für uns mal an die pvp damals
war das auch richtig hektisch aber auch
interessant zu sehen dass mein fach pvp
damals nicht so lange umgeht und warum
gespanne und werk der bessere
bauschheimer war sondern es war einfach
bei menschen aufnehmen dazu und haben
erst mal drei sekunden aneinander vorbei
dann treffen sich vielleicht irgendwann
der gefragten sekunden lag dazwischen
die zeiten sind halt so als ich da
selbst wenn ich merke aufgestockt habe
aber es ist irgendwie schon cool des zu
sehen
in diesem wunderschönen standort hier
können wir dann auch die video beenden
wenn ich jetzt vielleicht noch mit
anderen usern machen könnt ihr das gerne
in die kommentare schreiben bitte nicht
mal haut rein macht mit und können